a new gameplay trailer for demon souls
was just revealed and the interviews and
articles that were released alongside it
have basically answered every remaining
question we had about the game
stay tuned for what's new and staying
the same
in the demon souls remake first up
omnidirectional rolling
is finally confirmed you can kind of see
it happening in the flame lurker fight
and creative director gavin moore
confirms it is eight-way rolling which
i honestly think is just such a crucial
quality of life improvement
for new and returning players and a lot
of features like this
like the camera and the game's filters
these can actually be reverted back to
how they were
in the original game so the players new
and old
can get really close to that classic
experience if they want to
if you've read the comments on any of my
videos it's split down the middle
between people who want something new
and people who
really want to relive the original so
hopefully this pleases both camps
because
if you want that janky camera that clips
and gets stuck on everything
they've said you can enable that do you
want the game to be greener
darker and just less cluttered then you
can switch over to that filter
seamlessly and they're also adding a ton
of other filters
probably similar to what you can see in
their shadow of the colossus remake
there's even going to be a photo mode in
the game which will work
as long as you're not in multiplayer and
will allow you to pause the game and
have powerful control over your
screenshots
and i wouldn't usually say this for a
console game but as if you were playing
a pc game
sounds like the first thing you should
do when you boot up this game
is go into the options and just play
around with everything to find
what suits you in my opinion you'll at
least want to make sure that performance
mode is turned on so the game is locked
to 60 frames per second
and make sure your camera is in its
fixed mode not
the cinematic mode that you're actually
seeing right now and you have a second
set of options that are available to you
and they're actually located
in game in the nexus most likely at the
statue where you spawn in
here you'll be able to turn on fractured
mode which has been revealed
to be a mirror mode that flips the
entire game
horizontally so you can basically play
every map
in reverse you'll also be able to pay a
certain amount of souls
too and i quote store your character
here
this is really weird wording it's almost
implying that you'll be able to
sort of hot swap characters in and out
of the world
so if i go here and i look at my list of
characters and i change characters
does that mean the world also changes to
suit my character
am i just pulling one of my other
characters into this world wouldn't that
break the game
and if i'm just coming here to change
characters why am i paying souls for it
do you guys have any ideas i guess we'll
just have to wait and see
but mirror mode is actually such an
intriguing thing to add to the game
playing flipped maps might actually
throw you for a bit of a loop if you're
someone who is really familiar
with the world it might almost feel like
playing it for the first time a little
bit
and it's also really good from a law
perspective to have all these things
happen
in the nexus remember the fabric of
reality
is broken in the outside world and the
nexus is what holds it all together
so it kind of makes sense that the nexus
is also
what could control that reality and you
know flip the world horizontally
pull different characters into the world
that sort of thing
kind of makes sense apparently you can
also absolve your sins here and while
we're in the nexus we might as well talk
about the broken arch stone
spoiler alert we can finally confirm
that no new worlds or levels
have been added to the game and the cut
content behind the sixth
broken arch stone has not been restored
bluepoint says that they felt it was not
their right
to reimagine this cut content and while
i'm intensely curious about what that
cut content
could have looked like i think this was
the right
and honestly predictable decision unless
from software decide to collaborate with
bluepoint on some dlc
which would be awesome the closest thing
you're going to get to the world beyond
this archstone
is in the art competition we ran a few
months ago so
go and check that out if you're so
inclined but you have to respect
bluepoint's integrity here
they are mostly intent on this really
honest remake
that is pretty true to the original
developers intentions
as such you'll be happy to know that
there are no different difficulty modes
and even world tendency is in the game
in its
true and honest form although they say
now that you will
more easily be able to figure out what
level your world tendency is at
for each world so blue point clearly
have a line that they won't cross
for changes and now we pretty much know
exactly where this line is for them
but one thing that surprised me is that
according to the creative director
they won't be removing all of the bugs
in the game
apparently they're going to
intentionally leave in some of the
less consequential meme worthy bugs and
game design quirks that the game used to
have so i would assume this means that
they're going to leave in
things like sequence breaks which let
you skip parts of the level
and they've said they're going to remove
things like attacking bosses through fog
gates
but i've also heard rumors that the
duplication glitch
does remain in the game which i kind of
disagree with
but okay another thing that you might
not have expected to be faithfully kept
in the game
is enemy ai here we see the flame lurker
jangly running around the arena just
like he does in the original game
which i kind of love and i find it kind
of funny that it's still here
in this trailer sorcery is also shown
for the first time
we see a sort of soul ray here which
looks to be doing some sort of piercing
or aoe damage
and also strangely hones into different
parts of the enemy at times
we also see the kick animation briefly
and this really sick
backstab animation this time for the
mace category
of weapons and it probably goes without
saying at this point but
man the finer details and the polish
here are
so gorgeous when you spot them from the
lightning flash
through the roof of the tower of latria
from the incredible texture work
to the sound design blue point of best
in class
at this stuff there is no doubt about it
there is one change that i'm really
excited about
and it's for weapons so bluepoint says
that while the cadence and
speed of weapon animations will remain
the same
the animations themselves are different
which
is actually such a wonderful idea
because so many of the weapons in demon
souls
have exactly the same move sets within
their weapon class and
adding new animations is going to be so
good
for giving each weapon its own character
and the way these weapons
feel thanks to the new haptics feedback
on the controller
is by all accounts of the ps5 controller
nothing short of incredible go out and
watch some videos on that actually
i've been watching a lot of first
impressions videos and everyone points
that out
so because the mechanism behind the
haptics this time around
is so much more nuanced and better
engineered than previously
it can really simulate the feeling of
different surfaces or
vibrations so for example in demon souls
you should be able to feel a pretty
accurate simulation of
the material your weapon is hitting so
for example
metal hitting metal or metal cutting
through flesh
this should make the combat feel
grittier and more visceral
it's possible that the surface that your
character is walking on might even be
taken into account
which will make the environment feel
more alive the same sort of thing can be
said about the 3d audio
anything that enters your character's 3d
space will
be able to be heard like an enemy
sneaking up behind you
or an arrow whizzing past your ear
hopefully this all makes the game feel
more real
and weightier but you know what else
might be weightier your inventory
in the original demon souls there was a
limit to how many items your character
could carry
and honestly while i'm all for no
changes this sucked and i really hope it
gets removed or changed in the remake
but one set of items that are confirmed
to have weight
are your healing grasses which is the
consumable that you
heal with in demon souls now stronger
grasses
weigh more whereas in the original you
could have
99 of the most powerful grass and just
spam it so that you could never die
so this is a good change it sounds like
honestly the system is going to be more
like
bloodborne's blood vial system where you
can find
healing items out in the world but you
can only carry
a limited amount they've also added new
consumables to the game
there's a new category called grains
which
all give you different temporary
elemental resistances
you might have seen these in this
preview window which is showing off the
items that you get
if you buy the digital deluxe edition
and
man we're at that part of the video we
need to talk
about what is objectively the worst part
of this remake
so previously it was hoped that
all of the items on this digital deluxe
preview
were just simply early access items
we were all hoping that sure if you buy
the digital deluxe version
you get these items on every new
character you create you get them early
that
makes you more powerful but we hoped
that you would still be able to find
these items out in the game
even if you just bought the standard
edition of the game well
it's been revealed on the official site
that three of these items
are exclusive to the deluxe version
the redeye night armor boletarian
royalty armor
and ritual blade will only be for people
who spend
90 us dollars so that's 20 more dollars
than the standard edition of the game
which like all next gen games costs 10
more for some reason
the rest of these items will be given to
your character upon creation
but will also be able to be found in
game this is bad
you will be locked out of these
character equipment choices
if you don't want to shell out 20 for
these three items or
even pre-order the game for the reaper's
scythe up in the top right
i don't care if these items are weak i
don't care if they're not viable in pvp
sony's tagline for the playstation 5 is
play has no limits
and this is the limit this flies
directly in the face of that
now there are people you should and
shouldn't blame for this you shouldn't
blame the developers at blue point
you shouldn't blame anyone at
fromsoftware none of these people were
likely involved in this decision if this
comes from anywhere it comes from higher
ups at blue point or sony and
guess what that's where most of the
profits go to next-gen games are already
arbitrarily 10
more expensive and adding more shallow
rewards like this
kind of just adds insult to injury in my
opinion
now i'm not saying boycott the remake
but i think
part of being a good fan is just
honestly criticizing the games that you
love
and while i think bluepoint and sony
seem to be doing an excellent job with
the remake
this is not in line with what souls fans
have come to expect
and it's a slippery slope if we're all
okay with this kind of thing happening
it'll just get worse year after year so
in my opinion
sony should and probably can reverse
course on this before it's too late
and they should just make all items
early access but
still accessible in-game for holders of
the standard edition
i think it's the right pr move
considering their tagline
and yeah anyway subscribe for more demon
souls content at launch
here and also on my twitch channel where
i'll be streaming the game
in a couple of weeks now and i'll see
you there
you